the UK seen any evidence that South
Africa has provided weapons to Russia
and are you able to say whether or not
Storm Shadow has been used yet in
Ukraine and against what on the first
point I can't comment on
you know anything that I may or may not
have seen relating to another country
if it isn't a public statement by those
countries so I I don't think I'm afraid
it falls into the neither confirm or
deny anything in that area on the Storm
Shadow all I can say is it is my
understanding that it has been used
uh
since we announced its deployment to
Ukraine but I'm not going to go any
further details of that operationally